foot avec votre grand truc c'est des
habitations
oui notre hyper fort en imitation et je
vous avais reçu dans une émission et
vous nous aviez offert votre imitation
du vélociraptor voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous la refaire ici ou est ce que
vous voulez qu'on la passe comme tu veux
si vous pouvez nous la faire en direct
ok il fait très bien le velociraptor la
face aux bas ici aller là où il n'y a
pas assez d espace
ciba mettez vous l'allumez c'est juste
un petit interrupteur vais tuer alors
dans ce cas tu fais juste après moi non
mais moi je sais pas du tout permet
justement c'est ce rôle
allez-y faites le vous faites très bien
c'est la seule limitation vous faites
non je peux faire les hippocampes
situent eux au dehors alors vous êtes
alors attention la première fois qu'il
est fait c'est parti pour le
velociraptor
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
il faut quand même à l'époque tu fais
quoi que votre animal l'hippocampe jeu
l'époque on parlait d'une augmentation
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la dernière écurie la balle à la baleine
daba daba l'année après l'écureuil c'est
la baleine mais il n'y a pas de chez
vous les bras il est bien les curés oui
michael prophet après philippe joffard
michael jackson avait d'accord oui c'est
vrai mais pourquoi pas attention chez
vous vous nous rejoignez il va faire des
cures et ça sera là ces films là bas
vous fait un petit peu 2 merci à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pareille fête aussi très bien le dindon
mais en fait je la célibataire longtemps
le dob le dindon pour moi c'est moi qui
vous le dis je vais rester célibataire
et non les gens adorent les femmes
adorent les rockets elle est le dindon
ces mots nous rejoignent et fellow d'art
dont j'adore
[Applaudissements]
michael jackson mais pourquoi